jetzt schauen wir in den Bundestag der
Wirtschaftsminister Robert habecker
spricht guten Morgen eigentlich haben
wir besseres und Wichtigeres zu tun als
übereinander zu reden die Wirklichkeit
fordert unsere volle Konzentration und
Aufmerksamkeit dennoch möchte ich einmal
sagen dass der Sound der
selbstkritiklosigkeit den ich hier
gestern gehört habe eine Antwort
erfordert lieber Herr Merz 16 Jahre lang
hat die Union dieses Land kreiert und
viele Bundesländer 16 Jahre
energiepolitisches versagen und wir
räumen in wenigen Monaten auf was sie in
16 Jahren verbockt verhindert und
zerstört haben sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
und das tun wir mit einigen Erfolg seit
einer Woche gibt es kein Gas aus
Russland die Speicher füllen sich weiter
nach einem kurzen Ausschlag in der Börse
ist der Preis noch immer hoch und zu
hoch aber nicht explodiert seit einer
Woche sind wir unabhängig von russischem
Gas wegen der konsequenten und
vorausschauenden Handlungsfähigkeit
dieser Regierung und dieser Koalition
gestern hat Frankreich nachdem es immer
Abnehmerland war erstmals Gas nach
Deutschland geredet Erfolg von
diplomatischen Anstrengungen und
Bemühungen es war ein Testbetrieb
dennoch gleichzeitig ein historischer
dann ist verstärkt die europäische
Solidarität sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
der Angriff ist offenbar die beste
Verteilung das sagt sich Robert Habeck
gleich wieder mit einer Attacke auf den
cdu/csu-fraktionschef Friedrich Merz
wichtig aber auch dabei hat kritisiert
dass die Union ja eigentlich die
Energiewende über die letzten Jahre
Jahrzehnte kann man fast sagen
verschlafen hat die Grünen zu den Robert
habe gehört dirigieren ja mit und das
ist das was Robert Habeck verschweigt
das ist also nicht korrekt was er dort
sagt die grüne geh in den Bundesländern
mit in einem stellen sie sogar den
Ministerpräsidenten von daher Robert
Habeck ein bisschen mit Demut an dieser
Stelle wäre in Ordnung
war immer integraler Bestandteil unserer
Politik und das die Union in dieser
Krise in dieser Wirtschaftskrise
ernsthaft dagegen klagt dass die
notwendigen Investitionen in erneuerbare
Energien in Energieeffizienz in
Wasserstoff hochlauft und auch noch in
die Robustheit der Unternehmen
verfassungswidrig sein soll das ist
ökonomischer Wahnsinn meine Damen und
Herren wie wollen Sie denn den
Unternehmen wie wollen Sie denn den
Unternehmen erklären dass sie am Ende in
dieser Situation wo wir einen
nachfrageschock haben keine staatlichen
Unterstützung mehr bekommen es zeigt
bestfossilen geistes-
ich habe manchmal den Eindruck dass sie
überhaupt noch nicht verstanden haben
welchen Ausmaß die Herausforderungen der
Zeit das hat erfordern welche
Anstrengungen wir nehmen müssen welche
Umstellung auch in der Art wie wir
Politik denken notwendig sind
stattdessen immer nur weiter das
Oppositionen
oppositionsklänge und möchte gerne
Wirtschaftspolitik sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
was ist das wichtigste
das Wichtigste ist dass wir die
preismanipulation durch Putin beenden
wir können auf Dauer nicht gegen die
hohen Preise an subventionieren deswegen
müssen wir jetzt und werden wir das
energiemarkdesign so ändern dass die
günstigen Kosten an die Verbraucher
weitergegeben werden und die hohen
Kosten zwar noch den Marktmechanismus
geben aber nicht mehr durchgereicht
werden morgen ist der energieministerrat
in Brüssel die Vorschläge der Kommission
liegen vor man sieht wie gut Europa
arbeiten kann und sie gehen sehr in die
Richtung die auch wir vorgeschlagen
haben da sind wir auf einem guten Weg
aber auch das muss man aussprechen wir
machen etwas in wenigen Wochen was
normalerweise Jahre wahrscheinlich zwei
Jahre Beratung gebraucht hätte wir gehen
an das strohmarktdesign rein und wir
halten uns eine Option offen wenn das
nicht sofort und solide gelingt dann
werden wir über eine abschöpfungsabgabe
die Gewinne kassieren und den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zurückgeben
wir werden
auch
wir werden auch jadek ist doch
überraschend muss man sagen Kampf ist
lustig geht Friedrich Merz immer wieder
an und kommt jetzt direkt zu seiner
Beginn seiner Rede auch auf seinen
Lieblingsprojekt zu sprechen eines
seiner Lieblingsprojekte muss ich sage
die übergewinn Steuern die wird morgen
unter anderem in Brüssel verhandelt
darauf hat er gerade immer hingewiesen
und wenn es dort keine Einigung gibt
dann will die Bundesregierung selbst
übergewinne abschöpfen
perspektivisch indem wir uns nicht mehr
von russischen Energien sondern von den
fossilen Energien insgesamt losmachen
wer das verkennt wer das verkennt
verkennt in welcher Phase wir uns
eigentlich befinden bis wir die Preise
runter bekommen haben und das wird
sicherlich ein bisschen dauern bis wir
die Preise runter bekommen haben werden
wir den Unternehmen jede Hilfe zukommen
lassen wir werden einen breiten
Rettungsschirm aufspannen und wir werden
ihn breit auf Spannung so dass vor allem
die kleinen und und die die KMU's
diesen Rettungsschirm runterfallen
können was heißt das konkret wir werden
das Programm dass wir jetzt aufgestellt
haben für die Industrie das
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm öffnen
für KMU's wir werden damit die
handelsbezogenheit als Kriterium die
handelsbezogenheit als Kriterium
aufgeben wir werden es branchenöffnen
gestalten aber an Kriterien natürlich
festhalten Kriterien kann beispielsweise
der Energiekostenanteil an Produkt oder
am Umsatz sein es wird zeitlich
befristet sein weil wir einen anderen
Instrumenten arbeiten nämlich die Preise
stoppen und so das ist auf jeden Fall
nicht der Robert Habeck der bei vielen
Wählerinnen und Wählern so gut ankommt
weil er so einfühlsam und so einprägsam
spricht Robert Habeck ist aktuell
erkennbar angefasst erkennbar aufgeregt
und spricht sehr sehr technisch das Wort
KMU einmal nur kurz übersetzt das heißt
kleine und mittelständische Unternehmen
diese ganzen Fachbegriffe die hat ihm
offenbar jemand in seine Rede
hineingeschrieben es ist der aktuell der
Rede wirklich zu folgen
Energiekosten wir haben einen
nachfrageschock das Geld in den
Haushalten wird knapp deswegen werden
wir weitere Maßnahmen
wirtschaftspolitische wie vor allem
strukturelle Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
dass die Menschen in Deutschland genug
Geld haben auch zu konsumieren und so
die Unternehmen stützen können
beziehungsweise Unternehmen ebenfalls
geschützt werden die nicht nur alleine
über die in die energieintensive
Produktionsweise von dem Programm wie
eben skizziert erfasst werden und
fünftens werden wir im Oktober einen
Mechanismus auflegen wo Gas gegen Geld
den Gasverbrauch unterbringt und die
Unternehmen die dann in der Produktion
etwas zurückfahren schützt und
finanziell entschädigt sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Putins Angriff zielt
auch auf unser Wirtschaftssystem es wird
immer gesagt es ist die schwerste
Energiekrise seit 1973 das ist nicht
richtig diese Energiekrise ist weit
komplexer die Aufgaben sind weit größer
und deswegen müssen wir das was im jeden
Fall gut funktioniert jetzt hinterfragen
und ändern wir müssen das Marktdesign am
Strommarkt ändern wir müssen die
fiskalpolitischen Rahmen neu denken wir
müssen die Geschwindigkeit und die
Entschlossenheit mit der politische
Entscheidung fällen über hinterfragen
und verändern wie wir es getan haben und
wir sollten vielleicht auch überdenken
in welcher Rolle
Opposition und Regierung sich manchmal
befinden sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
vielen Dank
wir haben einen Wirtschaftsminister
gesehen der deutlich angefasst ist er
war kampfeslustig aber auch er hat
gewirkt als wer in die Enge getrieben
seine Stimme war anders als sonst wie
hast du ihn erlebt ja ich glaube das hat
jetzt jeder gerade gesehen Robert Habeck
hat sehr schnell gesprochen war
aufgeregt hat sich immer wieder auch
verhaspelt und hat anders als man das
sonst von ihm auch gewohnt ist sehr sehr
ich möchte jetzt mal sagen technisch
gesprochen hat viele fachtermine benutzt
KMU für kleine und mittelständische
Unternehmen hat von
Fiskalpolitik gesprochen von Marktdesign
das kann man verstehen wenn man Experte
ist aber ich glaube so eine Rede richtet
sich ja nicht nur an die Abgeordneten
und die Fachpolitiker im Bundestag
sondern soll sich ja eigentlich auch
richten an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und da hat Robert habe ich sich auch mit
dieser Rede keinen Gefallen getan was er
deutlich herausgestrichen hat ist dass
er als Wirtschaftsminister weitere
Hilfen in Aussicht stellt
gerade für die kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen also auch
dann für beispielsweise die
Bäckereibetriebe ein Bäckermeister haben
wir ja zu Beginn der Sendung auch
gesehen den soll stärker geholfen werden
da hat er gesagt wird er den Schirm
ausweiten wie genau das passieren soll
das konkret aber noch nicht fest
geworden das ist richtig genau und es
soll etwas geben er hat's genannt Gas
gegen Geld also Firmen die ihren
gastverbrauch deutlich reduzieren die
sollen dafür einen Entschädigung
erhalten er hat den schwarzen Peter in
Sachen Energiepolitik der CDU
zurückgeschoben seiner Meinung nach
waren die es die die letzten Jahre
versagt haben und er muss jetzt
innerhalb weniger Monate weniger Tage
zusammen mit der Ampel das alles
bereinigen berechtigter Punkt teilweise
berechtigt der Punkt richtig ist die
Grünen saßen jetzt wirklich viele viele
Jahre nicht in der Bundesregierung aber
sie haben natürlich in den Bundesländern
mit regiert und wenn wir sehen auch wie
groß Widerstand von
örtlichen ökologischen Gruppen so möchte
ich es mal nennen man könnte auch
bösartig sagen von Rad einen grünen
Aktivisten ist gegen beispielsweise den
Bau von Stromtrassen neuen Windrädern
dann müssen sich die Grünen auch an die
eigene Nase fassen und fragen wie viel
Doppelmoral ist eigentlich in dem jetzt
was Robert Habeck gesagt hat und
interessant ist auch der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister der ja
eigentlich
doch auch viele viele wie wir es auch
gerade gesehen haben Politiker anderer
rein die andere Auffassung haben gerne
kritisiert auch deutlich kritisiert ist
plötzlich was den Ton der Kritik ihm
gegenüber angeht ganz ganz
ja man möchte fast sagen dünnhäutig hat
jetzt zu Beginn der Rede und am Ende der
rede ja gesagt er wünscht sich einen
anderen Umgang das ist eine Methode die
wir jetzt wirklich häufig auch gerade
von den Grünen und im linken Lager sehen
Kritik wird immer automatisch als als
weiteres empfunden als persönliche
Angriff aber umgekehrt und das haben wir
bei Robert habe ich auch gerade eben
gesehen ist der mit Kritik ja auch nicht
gerade geizig was beispielsweise den
cdu/csu-f Chef Friedrich Merz angeht
also auch da steckt viel viel
Doppelmoral in dem was Robert Habeck
gerade gesagt hat die Einatmung von
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer herzlichen
Dank
[Musik]